you are listening to the hot breath
podcast i am your host comedian joel
byers and welcome to your weekly guide
to comedy mastery
with ali
sadiq
oh yeah you're a professional
you're a professional podcaster
let me see could you scoot in a little
bit for the the frame there
all right
ali siddique my man isn't that dark
right here does it look dark
i look dark
it looks good on the camera though it's
a good camera
maybe we can switch you want to switch
seats
let's try that
okay i look a little lighter is that
better for you maybe that's better oh
yeah okay whatever makes you comfortable
sir man it was just dark i'll take a
pillow though you want pillow yeah i'm
and i'm old a little set dressing old
man you're an old man
old man with new fame
i don't have no fame that's what i don't
have that's
damn sure what i don't have is fame what
do you think you have right now
uh i don't
i don't think i have anything i did i
don't know what it is that i have it's
like
i'm living that's basically it i'm
having a career and just living yeah
well i don't have
too much if
this is this is simple as this um
do you ever see me at any award shows
[Music]
i guess not
do you ever um
see me
in any of these magazines or you know
like comedy hype or any internet stuff
on me or you know i'm not i'm not a part
of most of these most of these things i
see you on comedy central
yeah that's that's comedy central you
know culturally that's bad to show them
somebody at the bottom of your foot
that's why oh really why i keep moving
oh is that where you're moving that's
interesting that's good to know man no i
never knew that
well i won't then ever again it's it's
um interesting yeah because if you think
about it the bottom of it what's on the
bottom of your shoe
i guess just what you've been stepping
on whatever you've been stepping on
outside oh wow just like it's it's a
thing where you know how people say
um cleanliness is close to godliness
right
that's the saying that he was saying
but yet and still they walk in their
house with their shoes on
or they walk on their place to worship
with their shoes on
it's a weird
concept when did you first learn that
showing the bottom of your feet was rude
just traveling and being around other
people
and being in reading like you're not
supposed to show people the bottom of
your feet
it's like
like somebody throwing a sandal at you
is in the end so like
when when they got through with
sandalwood bush
i don't think american american people
thought it was funny oh he threw a shoe
at him no that was like the ultimate
insult
that was like the it's no greater insult
in their
coaching than to throw your santa
gotcha okay it's like that's like
the bi it's like basically throwing
feces on you yeah it's the same
equivalent culturally oh well i just
learned something new there my bad no no
disrespect no no no i was just you know
i couldn't get a good angle
kept scooting and i kept like moving
you're like yo man your feet
your feet man i'd never heard that
before so i didn't know we're learning
every day
every day we learned we learned
something like i i i learned i was some
i was in on japan
and
this guy gave me his card
and i put it in my top pocket
and he was defended because i didn't
know that was rude
and and japan is rude to put take
somebody card and put me on top pocket
what are you supposed to do with it put
it in your wallet
or put it in your pocket somewhere where
you gonna
keep it if you think about it a lot of
times you put something in your top
pocket
you'll take the shirt off
in this guard you'll wash it or whatever
you don't think about what's in your top
but you just think about what's in these
pockets one time so i got it i
understood it i was like
so i remember that yeah so i asked
people now i'm like you you it's okay if
i put your car my in my jacket because
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna forget it in
my jacket pocket we went when the first
time i interviewed you in 2017 you had
just come out with your comedy central
half hour
and you were putting you were figuring
out the logistics behind your hour
special at the prison like you didn't
have a location yet
so now that you've had your special come
out you've gone to just for laughs like
you're you're in now like in the
industry speak so what have you learned
from being on the other side now
oh i think i think that's an illusion
that people that people have that i'm on
the other side and
um
i still have to request everything if i
if i'm not i'm i'm my afterthought still
and i don't think people get that i'm
i'm for sure
an afterthought
even even like you don't see me on a lot
of black anything
like
i'm not even mostly invited if they if
they put out a list of the top 100 black
comics i probably wouldn't make the list
why you think that
i don't know i don't i don't have a
reasoning for other people's um
ignorance i don't know
i really can't really vouch for why
you know
if they put out a hundred
top comics
income essential on conversational i
probably would make the list
you you did with when your comedy
central half hour came out you were like
one of the comics to
watch i know i won a competition to be
the comic to watch in 2013.
oh you had to win it what you're saying
yeah i won volunteered
i won a competition
so um the 42 jfl
you know i was in that because i had a
special getting ready to come out a lot
of things are
the
powers that be behind who pulling the
strings behind the scenes you know it's
like you're getting ready to do a
special so they gonna put you in all the
cert in all the circles but you're not
doing a special then you're not
in the circles
it's just that it's just that so you not
uh um i would have to be invited in the
same circles again i had to be doing
another special
to get back there yeah
what did you learn from being there
that you would have to do another
special to get back there that it
doesn't matter this is not a this is not
a
a
home situation this is a
visa situation i'm visiting
yeah i'm visiting basically
and doing comedy over 20 years you still
just being a visitor
and as far as the industry is concerned
okay
even even amongst even amongst black
people black people don't know who i am
that's why when people say you famous
you on us i'm like no i'm not i'm i'm a
regular joke me and you could me and you
could walk into
the same walmart and nobody say nothing
to me just like they you know wouldn't
say that to our average joe
you know it's not
it's not
um
[Music]
i sell our shows in certain places
you know
black people not coming to see me like
that more
white people come see me because i'm
more calm essential and they watch this
is not happening and they see me on that
so
if i'm not on
some slap stick show or
the shack all stars or something to that
all deaf digital or if i'm not running
in the shadow of um another comic
then
people don't know like people don't know
who i am does that bother you
no
why would it because
he would as long as human beings showing
up
you know none of it bothers me i i'm not
bothered by not being
considered one of the cool kids i'm not
i'm not bothered by that
i'm
because um
i don't think the people who they think
the cool kids are the cool kids i feel
you online
yeah yeah so it's like um
i'm not
i you know i i um i don't really get my
hopes up high about things like i want i
wanted to be nominated i got
in that circle you get what people start
hyping and i'm not about i'm not about
hype so
when you in that circle people are you
should be nominated for this youtube and
then you start listening
like man i should be nominated for emmy
with my special then you don't get
nominated and you look at the people
that are nominated you like wow
hands down if i'm just looking at it as
a consumer
my special was better
it's as a consumer as
if you took what was what's needed in
society my special was better
you took gold message
my special was better
going
you know not doing it
just with a
a backdrop
especially was better
being risky
is it people say well
it wasn't
originally yes it pretty much was it
wasn't it wasn't jeff ross roasting
prisoners it wasn't monique i could have
been your your cell mate or whatever
that was i think i'm coming from prison
coming from the situation yeah going
back to tell people how to get out of
the situation and how not to come to the
situation at the same time men and women
how did you
not what do you what do you think the
people that got nominated what did they
do differently from you man you asked me
questions i had that i wasn't in the
room with uh i have no i have no clue
so like maybe people just like agents or
publicists that got them in that
whatever
whatever
strings are pulled to get that
nomination that's what was poor
or whatever i have it go i don't i don't
dwell on things that i don't know
anything about
people ask you questions all the time
and you like well ask yourself that like
[ __ ] i can't answer some [ __ ] that i
wasn't a part of yeah yeah
yeah
like
i would i can't go back and do my
special different my special was what it
was
yeah it's just i've been doing comedy
eight and a half years and it's just
cool to hear someone at your level like
well no you just got to focus on what
you can't control because i'm just now
at a point where like i haven't been a
cool kid so it is that is almost
something i had to get over and then
thinking oh well i'd like to be here but
it's like but you're not so appreciate
where you are just hearing that
perspective from someone like you is
kind of
resonating with me and like where i'm at
in my career and i think a lot of comics
hit that wall too
man with
stand up
if you hitting any type of wall at
like
any you can't hit a wall
i can't even consider a wall until
like year number 12 13 14 15. i'm gonna
say 15.
because
for
it's going to take you 10 years just to
develop
what you actually want to start
developing
really
it's going to take you 10 years
to even get to a point where you can say
i'm going to start developing that
because now i kind of know
who i am and then two years in after
that you're still going to change
something up as it gave you a good comic
then 15 years then you'll be thinking
like damn i've been doing this in 15
years ain't got nowhere
but then
what you mean you haven't gotten
anywhere
personally that's what people think like
i ask anybody like what you mean you
haven't gotten anywhere
you went to school for 10 years you just
got out
of school
now you in college
for five years and then you start you
know what you mean what you what you
haven't accomplished
or you looking at somebody else's
accomplishment judging yourself
oh that's what it is
that that's how i
look at it most of the time oh you want
to be an instagram
sensation oh
no knock on them because they are
necessary evil just like just like
foley or
anybody else that decide to do
have a story need leaks you know all
these are necessary evils in a comedy
club
you know there's not
a magic show
anything else all necessary evils
for people who
really not pulling that many tickets
just yet
for them to
you know club to make some money
you know
then
you come in do the weekend and cultivate
real comedy and then you know that's how
the business works
yeah you and we talked about that in the
last interview which was like episode 73
now we're in the 140s so
it's it is cool to see even back then
where it's like people like from the
internet fame and the impact they're
making especially in the clubs going in
and selling out like a tuesday
like a tuesday seven o'clock show and
they can just sell it out it's like
that's just where that's a lot of the
demand is now nah that's that's that's
an illusion as well
because you got to think and i ask
people all the time it's a way that
people look at things without looking
it's like
i'm looking at this oak tree but you do
know it's a forest the whole forest
that's right there right
so it's a lot of other trees making up a
forest so
it may think it pushes people to
go on the internet and really give away
free content
if i'm a show producer i don't really
have to wait i don't really have to call
you in i can just wait
by noon somebody post something i can
write a sitcom off of mm-hmm
oh
no
oh just free content always yeah
volunteering just voluntary free content
that's one angle of it
two
name the um
the
internet sensation with us with a a
network special
i can't think of one off the top
you know i get you all day
see what cultivates comedy is comedy
that's gold
yeah
that's just
how it is
the stand up is not that and
and i look at it like this
you can go on a lot of
internet sensational pages
and they not posting stand up
right
you bet not
and your fans your fans don't post your
stand up no
your pants your fans
post your buffoonery
that's what they expect at the shows too
though if you're known for certain skits
that's what they want to see as your
stand-up is you just doing that skit
you're not gonna they're not gonna post
your stand up i don't give a damn how
many doors you you kick and how many
other people you talk about and how many
times you talk about getting sex or
giving head of being nasty that still
ain't stand up
and that's for the that's for the bottom
feeders don't nobody concentrate on that
you can have three million followers
that network's not looking at that
garbage we can't what it's going to be
what i'm gonna beat your whole special
even for the sitcom side they were
looking for compelling stories your
story very compelling we dove all into
that first interview but has anybody
approached you about wanting to turn
that into a sitcom or anything yeah but
that's not what i want to do i don't
wanna
put out another
prison sitcom or anything about anything
about that what i'm gonna do is gonna be
responsible
and that's not
responsible
you know the oranges new black and odds
and all around they can have all that
that's not they can they can live in
those fictitious prison stories i'm
you know lockup is doing a good job of
telling that story so
is that what people approached you about
it's like okay we have a vision ali
you're in prison is that what they said
that's what they don't that's what they
gonna approach me about it if
if they that's the work they've seen you
do they haven't you know they think they
that's what you own sale on
but i don't have a gimmick for them so
that's the thing i'm writing
about what i want to so
and that's the thing when it's not my
goal
it's no pressure on me
that's other people want me to write
sitcom that's what other people think
success is that's not what i think
success is because i'm gonna stand up i
didn't go to juilliard to be an actor i
didn't go to writing school i
i um
honed my skills and my craft being a
stand up
i'm not a talk show host i'm not a
um
gimmick writer i'm not a dancer i'm not
a rapper i'm not i am a comic
and i'm cool with that
maybe maybe i a
a old way of thinking
but i know people who uh i don't know a
lot of doctors who trying to do any
other thing other than being a doctor
yeah i don't know any lawyers who you
know
trying to be something else i think you
know it's certain crafts that people
have to be
what they are if you need butchers
i don't want my butcher
you know
want to be an actor and then i can't
give somebody gotta actually want to be
a butcher
so i'm just a stand-up that's it so what
are your goals with stand-up then what
you mean what my goals are well you said
the tv stuff it wasn't your goal i've
accomplished every goal in stand-up
really but what what more's for me what
is there for me to do other than keep
doing specials yeah your specials
because how many people how many people
get specials in
in their comedy career
very rare i mean more getting them on
netflix i guess netflix is starting to
pump them out but netflix is not coming
central
that that's the regardless of what
people try to oh you go to netflix man
if you go to netflix when you're trying
to
get to fight you can record your own
netflix special and sell it to him
how about that
but conversation you can't do that
i'd rather somebody put the money into
me to shoot my thing to know this is the
home that is in the title comedy central
the central location for comedy next is
hbo then i'll do a show time then we'll
get around to doing a netflix's that's
important to
me at that time but other than that
i'm just keep pumping out specials
because i don't think nobody ever asked
richard pryor when he was doing albums
or red fox when he was doing albums
um
what you want to do next
do what i want to do
they do whatever they want to do it and
i want the people who hell bent on
letting people understand that you won't
have to do
you don't have to be nothing else to be
considered a successful comic that's a
bunch of [ __ ] to me
i don't want to be have to become an
actor or something else to be considered
a successful comic what type of [ __ ] is
that
so i guess football players got to do
something else to go to the hall of fame
and football
so you got to do something else what you
got to do
yeah
to get the basketball hall of fame what
do you got to do you have to play
something else other than basketball you
got to play cricket too what you got to
do
so in comedy
why do i have to become an actor or be
in a movie or internet [ __ ] to be
considered a good stand-up
i guess just bring in a new awareness to
you get new new fans
if you're more if you're in more than
one place that's the more people can
find you but what does that have to do
with stand up though it can lead to
bigger venues
more
more so why do you have to do
do you understand what i'm saying why do
you have to do something else to be
considered a good stand-up
well if you're just a stand-up they can
only see you where they see standing you
just stand up that's what you [ __ ] do
you are a stand-up uh i love stand-up
but i'm asking why does a stand-up comic
have to do something else other than be
a stand-up comic to be famous for being
a stand-up comic
it's just the more awareness the more
you do the more people can see you why
people not aware but you're not doing
stand-up when they're getting aware you
acting you're saying somebody else's
words it's not [ __ ] stand up
but people say they'll start a podcast
what the [ __ ] what peoples they got to
do what the truth is i mean other comics
will do tv shows or other podcasts to
then drive new fans to then see them do
stand up
you know how [ __ ] stupid that sounds
[Music]
i mean i just do stand up i'm not on a
tv show or anything else
but i'm just thinking of what are the
most avenues that i can attract new fans
to then come see my stand-up and see me
live
so instead of me
maybe doing a one-night or somewhere i
can then sell out a weekend at a club or
sell out at a theater
it though all the vehicle is to drive
stand up but there's multiple ways to do
it beyond just stand up
i guarantee you you're doing a sitcom
your [ __ ] stand up sup
i [ __ ] guarantee it
i've seen that too
i've seen it a thousand times yeah i've
seen that too yeah
the people who was good at stand up try
to do other [ __ ] and then they [ __ ]
stand up sucks so then you're being
you're taken away from what you're
supposed to be in order to do some other
[ __ ] to get other fans to come see you
[ __ ] suck at what you're supposed to
be
yeah
just like people the internet the
internet [ __ ] are not good at
stand up live that's why they don't
[ __ ] show they stand up that's why it
doesn't make sense to me to try to bait
followers but not [ __ ] work your pen
and work your craft it's two [ __ ]
different things you doing sketches and
[ __ ] take cut action this [ __ ]
ain't nothing like me doing a live show
it's no comparison
it's no comparison
yeah
you're scaring me a little bit
so i'm just saying the understanding is
so [ __ ] up that comics have been brain
[ __ ] to think that you have to do
other [ __ ] and your stand-up is not
important when that's what you're
supposed to be
and let everyth and let that drive
everything just surprise standard was so
strong that his first [ __ ]
movie was about his stand up his life
jojo dancer that was his first movie
first movie whoa
i did not know that
wow
that's impressive that's how good his
[ __ ] stand-up was
yeah
and i think people have lost sight of
his stand-up was so superior that the
rest of the [ __ ] came he never abandoned
his stand-up
people trying to oh i'ma try to get here
to go there today come back no it don't
[ __ ] work like that
like live from sunset strip this is how
important this stand up was
he's performing live from sunset strip
he decides that it's not really what he
wanted to be
so he walks off stage
audience starts booing jesse jackson
runs through the curtain
trying to see what's going on he said
i'm not feeling it like you man you
doing you [ __ ] killing it
no i'm not
no i'm not
that's
that day
next day he come back
and now what is known as live
censorship is what you see now huh
he he acts the first he didn't even
finish the first taping of it no he said
i don't feel it yeah
wow
but it was going well
or okay i don't know if he was like
did you not just hear what i just said
he [ __ ] you don't be listening man i'm
listening you not listen i just said he
didn't feel it
he didn't feel it
wasn't [ __ ] wrong he didn't feel it it's
not my stand-up is that important
that it ain't about what the [ __ ] y'all
feel
it's about what i want to put out there
as far as a stand up i ain't feeling
this [ __ ] mm-hmm
i just told you jesse jackson went to
the curtain and said man what's going on
man you killing this like man i'm
killing this [ __ ] but you know i don't
feel it
how many times did you tape your special
it was you did one take and that was it
no i did two takes once one night okay
and how but i already knew what i was
going to do i already knew what i was
going to do
that's what it was and it's no feeling
from them i'm i'm
i'm crafty enough to know what i'm about
to put out there and nothing's gonna not
go well
nothing's not gonna go well cause i'm
already geared towards all this in the
way my standard the way i'm set up
how is not going to go well
how was it like how prepared was it word
for word like what you mean word for
word i don't
i don't
a lot of times i don't like people who
interview me that don't know who i am
i don't know who you are you can't know
if i am you talking i did something word
for word for word for what but you said
you knew listen in our first interview
you said you don't even like to do the
same set twice a week
so i was just asking for a special
though if you're trying to do this i
didn't i did one
half hour one one and a half like hour
20 minutes the first set then the next
that i came out and did a different hour
20.
okay
see i wasn't there for both so i don't
know i
know i know you wasn't there i'm telling
you i don't talk word for word uh-huh
never
but i knew what i wanted to do
i nailed it the first time that's why i
could go out and do whatever i wanted to
do the second
time they could they could put out both
of them back-to-back they two different
things wow
in the same day an hour apart they two
different things
how long in the comedy did it take you
to develop that confidence to just go
and not lean on the words as much
because that takes confidence and
repetition lean on what words
well as a comedian you can get stuck on
your jokes and this is how i said it and
this is how it worked but it takes time
to develop that confidence to just be
yourself on stage
man you you probably haven't listened to
me a lot because you you live in atlanta
i and i and i get that
man i don't say
a story the same way word for word ever
i don't think i ever do that
[Music]
because every
story has three i don't even finish
stories half the time
i don't even finish them
so
if some if i did
if i told the story right now
of the prison riot
which is affectionately called mexico
boots if i told this story right now
i wouldn't tell it the same way
that i did it when i recorded it
because i'm recording something i don't
have time
to tell the whole entire story
whether it was 16 minutes or 12 minutes
when i did it they cut it down to seven
so
if i actually do the story
that was about
a 45
to 50 minute story down that i'm
i'm just taking that long to say it
but it's long in that cause it was a day
it had that whole thing happened in a
day it wasn't like oh boom boom boom it
was a whole entire day from the time i
woke up that morning
in a riot in prison
lasts a long time
it's not 15 seconds
it's not 60 seconds
it's
the
the fight
the gas
the more fighting
the the police
the top being tied up the processing the
going to the infirmary the um getting
locked up getting um interviewed going
on tape getting put back in the sale
getting separated who getting locked up
going through the cases of being pending
they going through tape on you showing
you what you was doing it's a long
goddamn time it's not like
a second so it depends on what part of
the story
i want to say like i did i did the whole
story and i talked about mitch but i
never said nothing about red
i mentioned 240 shorty but i never said
nothing about the other participants
that was out there in a riot
it wasn't just two people
it's 300 people out here fighting
and everybody was in a different
position and i'm telling you from the
position where i was at up on the rec
yard on the side of the rec yard that i
was on it's two it's a two sided wreck
yard
it's eight buildings
it's a whole this is a whole place they
shooting gas from a central building
it's offices in rio gea it's a long day
how do you decide what to keep for tv to
say it on tv
i don't decide
i tell the story with the way i'm going
to say it
i don't
so i in
whatever whatever mood i'm in it may be
right on the fly i think of a part of
the story that i want to put in right
now
because i'm in the i'm in the mood to be
very intricate
right now and it wasn't it wasn't
playing it's like okay i'm gonna tell
i'm gonna put this part in like when i
just did the story because these people
asked me to do it
in orlando
and the dude walked up he said man that
was way different
then
i said because i never told y'all the
mexican dude's name
on
the tv now this time i told you his name
was alvarez
and he was like damn
he's right so
i never mentioned
the the other dude who told me what cece
was
a bunch of [ __ ] i didn't mention
but i'm now i'm telling you the story in
an intimate setting and i have more time
to tell you the story
it's more stuff that happened with
mitchell on how my plotting to kill him
was it's more things that happened in
prison than just the three stories i've
told
i was on six different units it's been a
lot it's been a lot of [ __ ] that
happened in the six years i was there
and i wasn't in just one riot
that's the whole thing that's just the
first riot
so it's a difference with you being you
being in a ride you being gassed so much
that you know when they using fresh gas
and when they not when they got new gas
when they changed things from pepper
from the gas they was first shooting the
co gas so now they got
um
pepper spray
gas it's like this mist that if you wet
it's just gonna burn whatever wet so
when you're fighting you sweating
so it's just burning anything with
moisture
so hey different is a different thing so
when i'm doing a story i may go up
in a night and decide you know tonight
i feel
just when i walked out here i felt like
i wanted to tell
this story right here
i didn't decide when i was sitting in
the back
something triggered me
right now to go here
for comedians that want to develop
stories like what kind of tips do you
have to help build a effective story
tell the story to your friends first
[Music]
tell the story to your friends
that's the simplest way
just say the story like
my friends
my friends know stories that i've never
said on stage and they wait and they
like
man one day he gonna do it i'm gonna be
there when he do this because this is
hysterical
but if i'm not thinking about it and it
depends on the audience that i'm in
front of too if i'm in front of audience
that really know me
which is not a lot of them
um
what was that west coast madison
wisconsin i think that was probably
about the
the most
that in dc was probably about the most
for me or this is me i think i've ever
been a part of because they it's like
they
went and watched everything
and when i got there
which was cool with me
i don't do a lot of old stuff anyway
they wanted some old stuff they was like
calling out stuff i was like oh okay and
so i would do
some of these old things but every night
i was doing a different show
i was just saying um what was i at
baltimore edmond goobies this lady came
to my show and she said i heard you do a
different show every night i bought
tickets to come see you
every night
every night
just to see
and every night she said you didn't
repeat not one joke
i said
i know
i'm not
i'm not telling you nothing that i don't
already know i already told you how i do
it
because i don't feel the same i don't
think the same from hour to hour
something else may have been on my mind
this is a different this is a different
audience but i said that sometimes it's
a headache because i be thinking of
something
and then i'm like damn did i do that
no i didn't know that this i didn't do
that this show
so i wanted so
i go through saying like i didn't i'm
not doing that this show i'm not doing
that i'm not doing that i'm not doing no
damn well i'm not doing that
i'm not doing that i don't even feel
like that
so i feel like doing this this and this
but if i get around to it then i'll do
it but
when i walk out there i just gauge it
from
when i get out there and see what i want
to talk about is it all in your head or
do you write it down right
okay
i love i
i said but that's another thing about
being a storyteller and
telling stories from your life i don't
have to write [ __ ] down
i just got to remember it just got to
come to my mind
what happened last night i told the
story that i hadn't
even thought about because wanda smith
was playing this song and they were
singing this song and i'm sitting there
thinking i'm like damn what's my memory
of this song
and i walked out
and
i told him i said man i had something on
my mind
but
this song triggered a memory
in my head that i feel like talking
about the dude say well come on with it
i said hey man what you better do is
wait
yes
boy let me tell you what's not gonna
i don't know what y'all accustomed to
but don't be hollering out nothing at me
and one thing don't rush me that's what
you better not do goddammit i just got
to work don't [ __ ]
um i told the story
and i kid and it murdered i said see
you can't rush me like other people
because i did the story about my mom and
my daddy and then that's
when that song came on it i knew it was
my birthday party no more
and
my mom my daddy ended up doing it
and when i said that's crazy they
weren't even together no more and then
people [ __ ] fell out because they
know they might make daddy
what are the keys to a great story
you know that out that i don't know
details do those play into like painting
the picture
for the most part but what makes them a
great story man it's like all these
people tell you these formulas that make
something great
when i'm when i'm telling the story like
bert asked me one time did i know what
made
um
madison got on boots prison story what
made that
a great story i'm like
i have no clue
it cuz to me is this a part of my life
that i told i didn't
i didn't
go into you know look i'm gonna make
this story great
i don't know how that happens
that's what he talked about with his his
russian mob story he said it took him
like three years to figure out how to
tell
and it's cool to hear another
storyteller being like i just kind of
say it
and it just works you know
it took him three years yeah
yeah wow
he said just doing it touring just
saying the story over and over again it
took him three years that that's right
because he says his word for word that's
probably probably right it'll probably
take me three years to say it word for
word and to get it down to one thing
and not add nothing else to it and just
say it that that that probably take me
three years so yeah i can understand
that because it probably some intricate
it's probably it's probably some other
funny avenues in that story that we
missing because he says and he's saying
it the same way all the time right
because bert is so hysterical that he
probably cut out something
some fat that he felt like was fat that
was probably
good
wrenching funny
but you would never see it if people
tell the story the same way that's we
can get lost as a comedian into like all
right laugh every 15 seconds got to keep
them laughing got to keep them laughing
what i love about your style and why dad
where did that [ __ ] come from where's
all these rules coming from man i don't
know and i'm telling you i remember
hearing this stupid [ __ ] man this laugh
per minute right what the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] man
it's like this is like new comics are
coming to the game [ __ ] it up man
just adding [ __ ] that don't really
what
please spit game on that because i i'm
lost in that right now of like well if i
don't get a laugh in 40 seconds and
they're not laughing then i i i'll that
silence you know i'm not comfortable in
the silence as much yet okay maybe
that's the thing cause that [ __ ] is
bothering me when i talk to young comics
i'm like man get out my face with that
[ __ ]
these rules
this dude said man he went to a class
to learn how to do comedy and then he
said he came to see me after he
graduated from the class
and he said man i can't see you and you
just made me feel like i [ __ ] wasted
my 500
because every single thing they told me
not to do you did every last thing
every last thing they said move the
microphone out the way you ain't [ __ ]
with that microphone you move you set
right in front of my world if you say
with your microphone like this
let me tell you
like
everything man
it's like you it's like i was like yo he
didn't he's not getting
laughs per minute
but you're getting these huge explosions
at the end like
what
are people doing to y'all
will you not being able
to be
comedy's about freedom
it's the it's the last
place for freedom of speech outside of
the barbershop
and i'm trying to understand as a as a
mid-range man i'm not old i'm not young
i'm in the middle
comic
it's depressing
for me to be the the the the one who's
still holding on to the
pure way
and it's kind of like
people
want to be pure but just [ __ ]
destroying
the mentality of what a comic is it's
like they [ __ ] with your brain with
wrong [ __ ]
it's like they feeding you artificial
food man and
it's like you're not saying that man
that [ __ ] don't matter
it's about you being able and it's not
like i'm the story this is just my form
of how i deliver my delivery it's not
i'm not a store i'm not none of these
labels this is how i deliver what i have
to say i'm the i'm a very dry sarcastic
i'm not i'm
what
because i was like that in prison
my with my skills of the uh home from
where i started being joviat that was my
my way of
letting them see hey man y'all just yo
[ __ ] the way you think man you're not
changing the way you think oh cause i'm
the person in prison that somebody about
to fight and i come in like so y'all
y'all about to fight i'm very
anticipating i'm just just a [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah so y'all bout to fight
what y'all about to fight about i just
want y'all to know this as the obvious
fighting
whoever lose gonna get their ass whooped
twice because the police gonna come in
and beat the [ __ ] out y'all and gash out
so yeah if you are y'all there man are
y'all that man mm-hmm
and they like are they staying at this
[ __ ] i'm saying i'm just saying i just
wanna
can i have your yourself once you get
cause y'all bout to go to solitaire i
just know you know just don't think that
you're gonna fight and they gonna come
in here and gash out and beat your ass
and you're not gonna go to the sides
here just just i'm just trying to put
other [ __ ] on your brain while you fight
each other behind whatever y'all
[ __ ] but go ahead go ahead
though
and
people will be in the day room laughing
like
yeah don't fight now the [ __ ] didn't
tell you what's gonna happen
so
i'm just
observational and i'm just putting it
out there
like it is
and i'm looking at things from a
different perspective and i'm not look i
don't give a [ __ ] about
laughs per nothing
you mentioned
comedian it's taking a comedian like 10
years to almost even figure out what
they want to talk about
does that come into play as well and it
took 10 years to even
have the ability to how you're funny off
stage to translate that to onstage it
took it took about that amount of time
to say you know it took me a little
longer
because
i switched
in the middle like right at the 10-year
mark i switched
everything up
yeah i switched everything up it was it
was a
it was a it was a smooth
transit because of how
people um
started doing stand-up it was like
everybody was kind of sounding the same
so i went a different a different route
i remember just saying you know
something this is this is more of me
you know i'm not going to dumb myself
down or dance to do all this other [ __ ]
to appease people i got i'm i'm not in
the i think that's the thing why i'm not
one of the cool kids because i'm not
chasing
i'm not i'm not chasing lads for my
audience i'm not chasing
um i'm not chasing fame i'm not chasing
followers i'm not chasing [ __ ] i'm not
chasing none of that [ __ ]
you know
because i really believe
what's for me is going to come
and i'm i'm very comfortable in my skin
with that so i don't look at little
duval
um song smile [ __ ] and decide you know
something
i'm because people know i already had
songs that i've never even put out
we got a song with zero that i never
even put out
it just didn't feel like it it's called
perfect i never finished it okay
man so
um i got a song with lloyd um
i got all type of [ __ ] i got some with
blind rob i got a song with gt i got i
got all type of songs with people but
that's not even that's not my focus it
started making taking me away from being
a stand-up so
my my stand-up is not about music my
stand-up is about
life so i don't really
i don't
i'm i'm i applaud duvall
you know just like i applauded will al
yankovic
when he was doing
true you know spoons and stuff him
saying
so
um
eddie murphy took a swing at singing
him saying jamie foxx did it jimmy fox
yeah i'm saying it a bunch of people
but jamie foxx wanted to be entertaining
a cedric
entertaining insane
so you know it's just
and anybody who gets anything i'm not
jealous
of them that that's for them
you know because somebody may be looking
at me like
i won't you want what i want what you
want you know
so
even with specials
that's
if that's gonna be my lane
i'm cool with my land i could be doing
cruise ships
true that and people who do cruise ships
kudos to them
you know they doing what they want to do
they're not chasing the fame they're
chasing they want to take care of a
family it's a it's a person and i and
people got to think about i want comics
to really soak this in
it's a comic that live in l.a
that
probably drives a maserati
got a good ass life
you have never seen him
headline a club
never seen him do stand up he ain't
nothing on nobody's show
none of that
but he's the warm-up for the price is
right
he's the warm-up for the ellen show
he's the warm-up
for
[ __ ] judge mathis
you ain't never seen him but he's living
a good ass life
doing he what you out struggling wanting
to do he living that life
without
you living that goddamn life yeah
dead ass doing what you what you want to
do
in front of a studio audience he ain't
gotta go nowhere he ain't got no tickets
everyone we gotta do [ __ ] but go out
there and warm the people up for the
show to start
you know
and that if that's what makes him happy
then that [ __ ] could jump in the
mother put his shades on and jump in the
mouth right and speed off the scene the
um the sony and the sony lighting yeah
you know your [ __ ] about what you do oh
i'm out on the weekends headline is club
she's like yeah good for you i'm going
i'm going to turks and cagos
this may have just made eleven thousand
dollars just wednesday and tuesday right
he's like what the [ __ ] why anyone gets
so rich he's saying days backwards again
thursday and monday yeah
and been a warm-up
for 10 years
career career warm-up
when you made the transition you said it
you're 10
you that's when you started being
yourself more on stage
that's when i changed my style
myself i just was saying yeah i just
changed what i was going to be talking
about i didn't want to talk about
nothing that somebody generally was
going to i was going to do a lot more
research a lot more studying and going
depth on [ __ ] and find the most gruesome
[ __ ] to make funny
and saying it even even
stuff that was inside me hey you ain't
you ain't you haven't been telling these
stories people don't realize people
don't realize this at all
i hadn't told a prison story
until i did this is not happening
whoa
and you've had multiple albums before
that that's some that's wow
i hadn't i hadn't told not one prison
story
what was that consciously or you just
said that was very conscious i didn't
want people to think i was some one
trick
oh all they do it's everything like no
right i'm not the prison comic
so it took me
16 years
i was going to stand up for 16 years
before i ever remember i did no eight i
did death game i was a season finale on
def jam
i was on common view 2001 to 2004
i was on off the chain i was on bill
believers who got jokes
i was on a lot of stuff before i did
this is not happening and you had the
vision to know i don't want to be that
so i'm saving that
i just not even thought i was going to
ever even do it was just
it's like i told stories to my friends
so they were like man one of these days
man you gotta say that on stage and i
never he's like
bill told me to say a bunch of stuff
and then the the
thing comes when
a person who is your mentor says hey man
you wanna be you want me to be real with
you
the funny
how funny you gonna be
is determined on how honest you're gonna
be
sure
i mean that's when
that's when you're gonna be different
when you decide that you have whatever
honesty whatever truth you want to say
that's when you're gonna start being
[ __ ] hysterical
and that was d.l higgly
just like when when sheryl underwood
told me
which sometimes she [ __ ] forget that
she told me this because she act like
she had forgetting she even know me or
some [ __ ]
but on the time join the cruise
i'll never forget it and and this is the
crazy thing
[ __ ] like she don't [ __ ] know me but
i said i say this story and very in
[ __ ] the detail is that i can
say it
because it's gonna be nothing but
straight detail
she was coming out of the spa
on the cruise she had on this [ __ ]
long flowy
thing that was like blue and green with
a little splash of red but it was white
based this [ __ ] flip big flip hat on
and
we talking and she said i had dreads at
the time
she said
ali
i'll tell you something
you want to be successful in comic you
got to remember these two things
every
man gotta want to be you and every
[ __ ] gotta wanna [ __ ] you
that's serious
and and i
and i
thought about what she said
and it's the truth
to be successful and stand up
every man gotta want to be you
it won't be funny
every woman
gotta wanna [ __ ] you
eighty-five percent of any comedy club
made up of women
if you are not attractive
no
and i'm talking about
one thing is you ask any woman it's just
a psychology [ __ ] when you go deeper
into it when you ask any woman
name your top three things you want your
man to be
i guarantee you [ __ ] funny come
up make me laugh come up i guarantee you
because funny and sexy
that transcends you pass what's your
physical [ __ ] look like
shane she was right
and so i cut my hair
i um i tailored up i was already
dressing with tailored suits and [ __ ]
but i tailored up more
i i switched my style up a lot
and
i combined what d.l and cheryl said
together
there's other there's other people out
there as well but
like dick gregory and dez white and rob
stapleton there's a lot of other people
who who gave me solid ass advice
so
when i get ready to write a book which
will be soon here um awesome it'll be a
book of
quotes
i think the story that i'm gonna lay the
story out of how i got the quote tonight
it's gonna be the quote
then it's gonna be the story behind the
quote
and then i wanna get the person who who
told me the quote to sign in the book
so the people i had that they were like
oh that this is original story so it i
would have to get
chappelle and
chris and some of these people don't
even know they told me important [ __ ]
you know
bruce bruce told me some super important
[ __ ]
and
it just it's just mind-blowing when i
think about
the [ __ ] that people jamario jamario
told me some people don't even remember
a lot of people don't remember who
jamario mario he is but he's a be the
big atlanta comic he was a huge atlanta
comic you look if you go back and look
up jamario jamario jamario mary was
funny as [ __ ] man
jamario told me saying man
again
you don't realize when you become a
headliner the type of pressure that it
has this on the headline [ __ ]
it's a lot of pressure on the headliner
you know people don't realize that a lot
of other things you're dealing with god
damn in the headline is rough
no [ __ ]
and then people don't realize that
you open and you feature and you get
spotting all that [ __ ] don't mean a
[ __ ] thing
hairline is a whole different
monster
not closing the show not going last
but you [ __ ] headline cause you
got a lot of [ __ ] to deal with a lot of
comedy come in front of you
yeah i'm saying mm-hmm
and a lot of [ __ ] is on you see a
feature ain't no pressure
appreciate no [ __ ] [ __ ] don't
nobody expect you to do a goddamn thing
you're just going out there you ain't
got to sell no tickets you ain't no you
ain't gonna buy did they nobody go if
it's just a lot man and then even as uh
even doing that you have to deal with an
unknown uh unknown hiccup that's going
to come on your ass that you not used to
you've been doing stand up
20 years
sometimes 25 years sometimes 15 and now
you headline it and don't realize a
check dropper [ __ ] your whole setup
cause you thinking you rolling then they
come drop them checks ain't nobody
listening to your ass no more you think
you're losing them nah they on they
checks
they gotta drop they check then they
gotta get back to you after that you
like god damn my show was like that
[ __ ] just fell out to the bottom
and then i ain't never come out of the
hole because you thought you lost them
unseen hand
the vicious check drop yeah it's
legendary
that's coming yeah that's [ __ ] coming
and
me being
a feature long enough looking at
headliners i think they bombing
then i'm like
hey
give me your tip
i know you've been doing a stand up 30
years but let me give you like a
lightweight tip
why don't you get them to signal you
if they pop drop checks
like i do i just get a double like
huh i say well i'll just ask that i said
when y'all dropping the checks
and
they say well we used to drop the chicks
about
45 you know like 25 to 30 minutes at the
headliner
that's how we know how much time see
people a lot of comics don't want to
learn the business enough they back in
the green room doing whatever the [ __ ]
they doing and [ __ ] and not
putting a show together it's still some
most [ __ ] you got to do once you become
a headliner you still got more [ __ ] you
got to do
so
you tell the person
hey when y'all getting ready to drop the
checks y'all do it like that give me a
double light fight me that that let me
know all the checks bout to drop so let
me not go into no intricate [ __ ] or no
real long story another let me just a
bunch of quick pop [ __ ] because i know
they about to go on checks
okay or they can't do that we'll do this
for me
drop the back
first so then i have the front
then drop the front then i had it back
i don't need the whole room
away from me at one time
i'm saying yeah
just [ __ ] that you gotta put in place
for your show to be successful
i've never heard that before
that's gold and if anybody ever say they
ever thought of their [ __ ] lie
i was the first comic
because i know i know other other older
comics that never thought of [ __ ] they
was like yo they might [ __ ] jeans
with that [ __ ] he's [ __ ] genius with
that because i need you to know
because
a comedy has to know we all in this [ __ ]
together
so
i can't have you just like with a weight
staff i want a weight staff as low as
possible i don't want you standing up in
the middle of my [ __ ] show cause the
people behind you can't see
i shouldn't have to come in and groom a
weight stab but the comedy clubs are not
[ __ ] focused on what comedy should be
because you so busy trying to just make
some money let me get the [ __ ]
sensation in here but [ __ ] get your
[ __ ] weight staff together and the
shows can be a lot more
consistent have some continuity to them
so how do you share this info with them
is there like a meeting
yeah i tell them straight up hey man i
don't want the wait staff standing
straight up
okay
take orders from here because that's how
it's done at my home club at the improv
i never [ __ ] see the wait staff at
the improv
i don't have to have no meeting with
them because they train right
they train right
they they're [ __ ] amazing staff i nev
they like ghosts in the room i never see
them
they're not blocking
consumers way trying to give some
consumers something else even when they
serving food they come somebody come put
the thing down and they get the [ __ ] out
the way and then you come and you put
the tray down and you serve the food low
they they get out the way they don't try
to distract anything from what's going
on on the stage because that's what's
important just like this is important
mm-hmm
dude thank you so much for doing this
first off
you dropped gems on this seriously like
the first one you dropped a lot of
knowledge this when you're dropping a
lot of knowledge
uh before we get out of here is there i
mean a lot of comics listen to this as
well
um but is there anything else
wisdom or anything any insights you want
the world to know man i just want
there's a lot of comments in this man i
really prefer and really want comics to
stop being so [ __ ] programmed
because it's [ __ ] the game up
it's just really [ __ ] the game of
where you are
programmed and they [ __ ] making you a
a robot
it's like they telling you what to do
now
and stand up
that's perfect but hey everybody do what
they want to do yeah like like hey
whatever y'all doing
do that don't let my words encourage you
to do something different because
this is my lane
this is the path that i've chose
i'm saying so
you may
you may choose a jr rider jr smith path
some people choose the kevin durant pad
some people choose lebron pass you
saying it's all about the path that you
choose they all in the nba
they're all they're playing
them saying
but
[Music]
somebody gonna be
looked at a little different than others
always
just trust yourself and your ability hey
sometimes don't trust yourself cause you
yourself may be [ __ ] up
yo you may have a dishonest self it was
there you gonna trust yourself like now
you might dishonest
i can't even be honest with myself
well i had a i had a comedian ask i
posted on social media seeing if people
had questions for you like people that
listen
and i had a dude he goes by go mookie go
so if that's what
all right
go mookie go he asked uh what was the
moment you knew you were going to be a
great comedian
i'm not a great comedian that's an
asinine question that that that is
determined by
individuals some people say i'm great
some this lady told me last night that i
was a selfish comic
she said everything you said was about
yourself i said well [ __ ] it was my show
yeah
somebody else i talk about me and what
the [ __ ] i think
selfish comic well oh this this is what
everybody thinks now i'm not that's not
what um everybody didn't even live the
same life as me so my you know so i'm
not a great cop i'm just a comic and
most people come to hear your point of
view on the world that's why they're
there they're not there just to hear
what they know see that's when the
audience don't know you see i'm not
popping out here yet you know it's just
it's still the
paper the room stage god i'm very i'm
very
aware i'm not i'm not a loser i know
where i sell that and why i don't
gotcha
all right and the last one here
for my his name is vic mc
and he said what were some of your goals
early on
to be
um
one it was just to get on stage and just
talk in front of people
then
i got a very i got a place in a very
particular spot to be next to a person
who gave me a good perspective
on things other than dl's perspective it
just complimented dl's perspective
another comedian named billy d
washington
he told me he said man i always remember
this man when you not being funny
be interesting
what
you can do that
and that's what i am
i took them words that's another quote
took the words and ran with it
so even that interesting may be silence
but you still have them engaged
it was a goal now
in the middle like maybe year number
three
i decided
to develop
to take on this this this goal of being
to the point of sitting down because you
know
dez white could just come out he could
just stand there
not move
so i i took that
and i could just
just do it just standing there
paul mooney sat on the stool
so i took that
and i developed that to be able to do it
from sitting on the stool
on sj was real busy around the stage
just air all the way so i took that
and i can i can do like i can be like
that as well
um
and then the ultimate [ __ ] was
sitting down
and being able to sit there for
just straight come out sit down then
um with no music was the second was the
next develop just come out no music no
introduction just come out and sit down
y'all already know who y'all here to
see and i just walk out
and it's the it's the type of goals that
you give yourself
to say
but you have to
be funny enough to
do that on a consistent basis like just
to come out like anybody now they walk
out they come out and sit down and say
hey
they [ __ ] stole it from me
because i'm the only one that does that
i did on tv and then on comedy central i
just come out sit down and say
hey
anybody else that does it is a copycat
anybody now i tell right now if you
trying to sit down you got it from me
you didn't get it from bill
because the difference is didn't nobody
do it
for 40 years
have nobody sit down for 40 years since
bill cosby
yeah you can't think of one comic that
came out and set in a chair
since bill cosby
and then i came out on both my
conversation special than did it you
know every special it's gonna be the
same i did it in prison came out and set
out in the [ __ ] chain prison on a
special like so [ __ ] you you know this
is me so if you doing that now you got
it from me because i'm afraid that
you're watching now you're not watching
bill um
just simple it's just
just that goddamn simple if you going on
stage you trying to lay back and tell
stories just [ __ ] pay homage to where
you got it from
because there's two specials out there
with me on it doing it just like that
and it's not another [ __ ] person out
there outside of me and bill cosby
that's on tv sitting down doing stand-up
find them
there's such a power in having the
audience come to you instead of trying
to go and grab them that you make them
gravitate towards you exactly
but i'm very under i'm very underrated
under appreciated
that's one that's gonna bring it back
bring it back to your you famous
no i'm not
no i'm not
and i we could be we can be in a um we
is at this big place in oakland bruce
bruce and was hosting and they were
moving was like is he gonna go out there
and running
people when they put that child there i
walk right out there and sit down and he
was like and murdered because i'm funny
where i'm where i'm at yeah i can i can
take your ass off right
why i'm at sitting down
with my feet crawl just like this and be
like let me tell y'all something um
this got to be the most comfortable
position
like it depends on what i feel like
talking about i came out and said hey
never buy
a shirt when you're on mushrooms because
every shirt looks good
and now that i'm not high no more out
this shirt was a very bad decision
and it'd be a certain people like hey
that [ __ ] is kind of straight
but this is awful now this is atrocious
like
first of all you shouldn't be allowed to
sell no [ __ ] like this
but hey
depending on what i feel like i i read
something right before i come out like
man
people out here wow man do you know
that a 99 year old man
in a 97 year old his wife 97 they
getting divorced
wow
[Music]
you know why you getting divorced
because he found out that she had an
affair in the 40s
not in her 40s
in
the 40s
you just now find out they didn't make
them home man she got away with that
yeah man you going to let that go man
statue she probably told him
mean he was in the 70s
and he forgot
and that's what i come out and say
because that's what i want to talk about
and that's my whole thing like you gotta
let stuff go
women when can we
when are you gonna stop
being mad at me about [ __ ] that you're
supposed to already forgive before
that's what i said and that's the lead
in
to that
so
it depends on what
happens
i can walk out hey if you
in your yard you dig in a trench
and the trench collapses on you and you
die
shoot your family
and tell everybody you at
home perfect
oh i read that
what was what was that advice bruce
bruce told you you started to reference
it earlier
bruce bruce said
never
quit your job
until stand-up is making more money for
you
than your real job
because he he said he was working at
fredo la
and
i said
probably not eating all the chips
i love bruce
and
that was the thing it's like this advice
man
that people give you
and you hold on to it
and you put it in the proper place when
it's the proper time
you see that check and you like
you know something
i can make more money doing stand up in
this [ __ ] on my own
and when you make that decision it's
gonna [ __ ] be hard man
it's gonna be it's gonna be it's gonna
don't think i'm saying it like it's just
gonna be some easy [ __ ] it's gonna be
hard and you're gonna feel lost at a
point like man god damn i quit my [ __ ] i
know now i got the rhythm this rent is
due
and i gotta find
a gig
that's gonna pay me
i gotta i gotta have it lined up so
when i left i had it lined up like man i
had all these shows lined up and i said
i'm i'ma make this amount of money and i
just more money i make over there i'm
out i'ma say it is that and then
you got eight nine ten shows lined up
six of them fall through god
damn
now you gotta you gotta hustle so i've
been doing this since 1999
with no other job
no other nothing
and it should have been hard sometimes
but yet again
from prison to on comedy central
and i'm still underrated
boom
ah dude thank you so much for doing this
seriously i i appreciate you and what
you're doing and the you're not
underrated
in my world of comedy in terms
you're one of the best and i say that
without any hesitation
so thank you for being willing to sit
down and do this again man yeah i mean i
i um i appreciate it man you um
i liked the first one that we did you
know
we get we get a little intense every
time we talk yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah oh i feel it's like it's like
it's like uh
like how cocele and my valley is no no
look i had great
intense interviews with him
he'll look back and like no no no no no
i have the best footage like yes yes yes
like bird bird like
i have people kind of like no if you
want to have good footage at my funeral
these are the four people that you need
to contact
like no no they have the best [ __ ] like
they have the best [ __ ] like it's like
joy diaz has
some good stuff joy d is like oh no no
brother when you when you [ __ ]
when you die now i'm gonna put this [ __ ]
out and like yo it's gonna be
spectacular like what the [ __ ] do you
think i'm gonna die before you're old
are you saying we're in that level where
we captured some unique ali
yeah man it's it's
every interview is is is different with
different people that's the craziest
thing it's like just like my stand-up
i'm different
with different play but it's it's
genuinely me
it's just a different
people bring out like i'm very
comfortable with
brain burp talk about what if i laugh a
lot
with him because he's just
when somebody come into your room with
no shirt on and yeah no shoes any
toenail one toenail pain he's like
so were you raised by a single mother
like what
that's like jumping into this thing yeah
don't sing a mother right okay all right
so um cause your room is amazing
i'm like no not right now but you know
it's like
it's just a it's a weird thing man and
then ari is a little
weirder the art is like yo we should do
shrooms together and then do a podcast
and then you think about it like
and then you go to joys and get
wasted with joy like yo and you're
waiting to do rogan
you want to do tom score you want you
know you just people that you want to do
you know you want to say i want i have a
goal of doing
these podcasts i want to do
you know times go on i want to do
brogan
i want to do i want to go on i want to
be the first person to ever go on um
bill burr's podcast i think he just does
this by itself he does like yeah i just
i want to go on billboard's podcast
just just me and him mm-hmm the only
person they ever do
they go down in history and i put that
in the credit the only man's ever do
bills
that'll be my uh i'll take all the rest
of my [ __ ] out comedy center and all
that they're like
y'all
come to this day give it up for all easy
d the only man to do
but that's my goal with this podcast
because so many comedians have a podcast
that i want to talk to comedians in a
way they've never been talked to before
and like get more on the insights of
their process and like how they got to
where they are and things like that
because so many comics have a podcast
i'd like this to be one where people can
come to learn i don't i don't do
everybody's podcast
just just know that i don't i by no
means do i do everybody's pocket
respect i have no desire i do joke
buttons
[Music]
but i i don't have a desire to do it
i'll do anything with nikki glacier
anything
with nikki glenn well thanks for letting
us be a part of that exclusive list
ollie sadiq oh yeah it's only uh
it's a very exclusive list
worldwide 20 people i'll do their
podcast worldwide it's not a lot of
people
because i don't like a lot of people
you you i've been in radio interviews
what the [ __ ] thing got like man you
know i will [ __ ] out you in his
interviews like it
like a lot of who the [ __ ] is you
talking to on the radio interview so i
don't like doing a lot of different
people's interviews yeah and i'm like
[ __ ] with you [ __ ] you do you [ __ ]
stooge
and then if you like yo we what we gonna
do this [ __ ] is he told me that he's
gonna beat my hands and he's like yeah
like i don't give a [ __ ] about coming up
here no one you can ban me you don't
give a [ __ ]
hey
man well you can't a dude like me that
that been in prison that know he's not
ever going back like i'm a whole court
in the street if they ever try that
[ __ ]
it's not a lot you can [ __ ] say or do
to me that i'm like yo man either you
gonna have to try to prove that [ __ ] god
i'm gonna prove exactly what i said i'm
doing i guarantee i'ma [ __ ] prove it
because i don't come from a place where
you can say some [ __ ] you can't do it i
can i was six years in prison my
informative years 1925.
if i say i'm gonna do something if i
make that decision you know something
you know um
i'll [ __ ] kick your teeth down your
throat
just know you're gonna have to go to the
dentist
[Music]
yeah and you're capable that's what's
scary just know you [ __ ] going to the
dentist it's like i'm telling you you
didn't you didn't push me too but like
yo man i go over here eating sugar
babies and you used to start [ __ ]
with me
and then there it is man all of a sudden
then i lead a bad guy but nobody else i
try not my best not to get into nothing
because it's always my fault no matter a
dude could shoot me
and then i'll beat his ass then they go
like see
see that's why the [ __ ] shot you
because you be like no no i got shot if
you not you know something [ __ ] man
[ __ ] playing everything on me [ __ ] it
man
i gotta look at it man it's [ __ ] man
whatever yeah i want to end this before
i get kicked in the teeth
nah man you good man that's what's up uh
our um
i was our um dialogue with just very
muhammad ali howard costello
i'm gonna go watch some of that i gotta
i don't even know the reference why
would you see the reference you're gonna
[ __ ] fall out you're like
yeah that is
it's kind of like this thing
because they were at each other all the
time they were the bet they always had
the best goddamn interviews that's
awesome
that line was muhammad ali
the critics say that you're not
what you used to be
and how and he told how go say he'd say
well howard
i talked to your wife last night and she
said you have the man that you used
yeah every time i'm gonna go watch
something i'm gonna come to your show
tonight too i'll see the master at work
i always learn seeing your work man
hopefully it's good man it's just been a
bunch of [ __ ] shows here man i did i've
been doing good but i just hate that i
gotta go back in my crate i'm not doing
none of my new [ __ ] or the [ __ ] that i'm
really engulfed in
i i must i'ma say this i'm gonna say
this boldly and it's not just the
atlanta people's fault it's the comics
fault as well
comics out here not the old cats not the
old cats not the henry welshes and uh
rodney perry's and the
male uh malik s's the other world and um
you know all the old cats
out here um jj from the sip
you know people who've been around
these younger guys man y'all got to just
stop talking about [ __ ]
and
getting high
and
people ain't [ __ ] [ __ ] ain't [ __ ] like
that that [ __ ] is dumb and audiences
down so when real people come to town
it's like [ __ ] pulling teeth to get
them to taste caviar
i'm saying
i don't want to have to go to the punch
line
and to get off my real good [ __ ] or the
laughing skull or somewhere
and you know usually i don't take gigs
at predominantly
um
anything wrong just one was one
predominant thing i like a mixed
audience
and
a well-read audience you know somebody
who know
what current events are other than
what's going on on [ __ ] youtube and
instagram type [ __ ] right you know
you know i need you to know that the fda
just did a recall on [ __ ] heart
medication that control blood pressure
say it's causing cancer
and i'm like that's some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
that
you got your blood pressure under
control
and now you got to go to chemo
which got you they stretched got you
stressed out now your blood pressure
back up this is like a [ __ ] circle of
death
that you paid for it that you paid for
it
and that's not gonna be funny if you
don't even [ __ ] read the paper
boom
we out here ali sadiq
appreciate you buddy
[Music]